you
all right
we are kicking off here for HS 960 arena
let's see who we get okay John John wick
about 30 some players and we have a
little countdown here I like that I like
that one so
I think I want to start with this I like
this for no
now I'm gonna go as this one
you'll have my Bishop to breathe
and then this
buon
what's he going to do this is the one
piece that's going to take some time
I'm oh okay oh and let's this is not
increment that's an adjustment
um I'm gonna commit be a little careful
and this kind of stuff could be annoying
um that's my plan to kind of lock it up
grab some space
yes I'm doing this now how many pawn
moves do I want to make
make another one
gotta get him out
so can I get away with this isn't the
question is the question I have I've
just made a bunch of pawn moves
is it okay to do that
I'm ready to make another pond move
this pond is going to cancel out him
this pond is going to cancel out him
bishop here castle night here night here
that's the plan
see how
and see if it happens
there's the what if there's a way to
take advantage of this it would
well let's go here on this I think I
might just take and then give the night
a shove
and he's my better bishop I don't really
like doing that
what's the queen doing
am I really afraid of her
that's just um
I'm not really afraid of her right there
I just I want to restrict a little bit
adjustment playing a increment for
several hours and now we have this
I want a queen exchange
do this I dropped that pawn though
what's most important he
this I think I want to do that before I
even develop my Knights
I think I have things under control over
here
let's try it
bom-bom-bom
he stood he's defended so I don't have a
fear of this
clean here
bishop here next
close to winning
just strategic when a really good
position
okay
you know where else
gonna go
you that he's unprotected
let's get the bishop on a better square
what's he doing
I don't care if I lose my light square
bishop
my pieces are falling on good squares
now
take with the Queen I don't want to drop
this guy he's he's he is an imprisoned
bishop he may never
never find
something good to do
inside castle it is
you can test the open file have good
control
I got away with these several pawn
advances
now this space advantage is telling
they're okay with the night in the
corner so what they're going to do
how do you win this
start with this how's he ever getting
home
it's babysit
babysit this pawn reversal
and they get my King on a safer Square I
guess
let's put this knight on a good spot
I think I want to jump in here soon
to defend some entry squares from the
Queen
light on over with my king soon
they're playing without a bishop now
let's make sure he never even gets to
move as some type of pawn sack
then we'll go here next okay now he's
dead
so
we'll go here
the night is still dead
Quinn shred
I'm up a piece okay there the breathing
space for the bishop but I have I have
everything under control my knight wants
to go here now
No
he's there in time I got it covered
and go here
in these ponds and to
these pawns and the Knights will push on
through night here
and we're getting a cleaning
oh did I also low reputation Oh
oh my god if that happened I would have
been really upset with myself okay don't
don't go back and forth with your queen
like that next time
like gonna go to a different square
maybe
alright well that one turned out really
well
my opponent didn't manage to liberate
his dark square bishop
terminal okay we have some time here
let's think this one's through
hmm I'm drawn to this
and
I'm gonna go with it yeah this is very
sensible okay that
now I think this is necessary I'm ready
to do some kind of no no what am I
talking about this is hit
got a defend that's right I forgot he's
unprotected I didn't do a scan in the
beginning so this guy is unprotected too
so when I do this
and this is what I am leaning towards
with my beep on but not here
now I think my opponents bishop is in
trouble
because of this move this is close to
just being a I know it's like my bishops
already fiend ket owed
here castles he's a little bit awkward
it's like a UH an accelerated something
right shut up and make a move here here
here and then here I want to establish
upon on d5 and make the bishop cringe a
little bit
I thought they
I try that move I don't think it's a
good idea it's speeding up my
development now
I'm soon going to have a massive Center
I'm going to be playing with a space
advantage and I believe a better bishop
let's keep the space here put the knight
on this square
Castle kingside I'm not thinking about
I am NOT think
about B for now
things have
changed a little bit
even see anything
what to do about that let's start with
this I don't know what I wonder with my
bishop yet
I think I want to do this
let's do that it's a little bit of a bug
can I go back here
here's what I'm thinking
h3 night h2 Knight g4
like that idea
structure for sure
this is feels like the only way for them
to play
these pawn advances I'm not sure what
they do this would be scary
it feels very weakening this would
expose the deep on
all right let's let's go for this idea
I'm okay with a double pawn
doubled h-bonds
let's do this so
was like there be some mate right around
the corner now
not castling
I'm anticipating that my knight will be
captured so I want to keep my rook here
okay that that weakens some squares I'm
going to keep my knight around
so let's keep some pieces on play with
three minor pieces castle by hand and my
pieces are now falling on good squares
my rookie here anymore this isn't gonna
open up so I'm ready for this advance
right now is that the time I think now
is the time
and I can follow up with queen bee -
Queen here there's a knight move with an
attack
let's go here with check and how to
improve
mmm they're in a pen
mine I could do something better
my queen could do something better while
here here and then threatened maybe
Knight to f5 stuff
want to keep the cleans on my queen is
far more active this is a serious threat
King has to find a new home
there's an there was a night move there
hmm
I'm going to reposition my night guard
this square
I think I want my knight on f3 g5 is an
excellent square now that h5 is is in
there
okay I can't do this because I'm on the
night
they're also lay down in time my queen
is in a good spot my knight is in a good
spot
she just drop all the way back maybe
this diagonal one of these three
preventing it all
okay let's jump in the center c6 is a
square I could work with
truck up and over
it's that about
you
right here
now they're in big trouble
discovering who this next one's gonna
hurt they might resign they don't want
to let me pull off this next move it's
going to be too painful
okay they're still playing on
pile up on this guy next
in my night doing something
my night
defense
here we go pac-man
checks
where's the mate there's the mate back
to tournament
okay I believe that one was yet again
another case of I know I'm getting a
good position out of the opening
I was allowed to form a strong pawn
Center
from there
started with that advantage and then I
kind of built on that
okay what arrangement do we have here
this is a nice
suggested the 960
Bishop's are fianchetto they don't need
to move to be productive
okay I still got 40 seconds to come up
with something
I'm thinking about this move
I'm also thinking about this move
here here here here
I'm cool with that I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go with that
t five night here
a better square for him
I could go more conservative with a six
and nine year why would I want to do
that to stay out of my bishop zwei
now we'll do this to combat this advance
yeah I'm king in right now I'm seeing
away I just I think King in on e4 is a
good idea
I need to move my knight in Queen before
I can Castle kingside
let's start with this
this night could be a pretty big bother
you
let's see
217
let's start with this
and actually I'm gonna do this right now
primary reason I I want to be able to
take control over this square as soon as
a knight arrives there
let's it improve my queen now I could
Castle kingside
if I want I could also Castle queenside
now that my queen has moved with this
last move I could castle in both
directions
I want to start with this he has to see
I'm controlling this square I have some
squares here this is a possibility this
is a possibility
I'd like to see a white commit their
King before I do okay I'm cool with that
and I don't mind seeing this retreating
move
well he has to at least see
so there we go
these are two moves that you probably
could have expected with our arrangement
okay
[Music]
I'll take
and I'm gonna go
yeah I'm gonna Castle kingside here here
regardless of what direction the king
goes I may even want to do this without
prepping first we'll see own and now no
I'm definitely well actually yeah I'm
going
hmm I'm going here right now pawn takes
pawn I'm taking the bishop I'm allowing
them to take my knight
yeah and if you're not catching it I'm
counseling by dropping my King on top of
my rook
in Annie
get positioned like so
okay let's put them here
and let's take like this first
why did I do that well I want white to
have a pond here I don't want this file
to become open or half opened now we
take here open up this and this move I
could go here
sink in here Bishop takes Bishop I'm
fine if the rook is going from be eight
to eight that's not some type of
demotion
have a big time edge
in the muff upon
we check
sure what that really does after the
king moves
okay let's just
take him out
now this is going to hurt
hitting the rook heading c2
stop a queen
I needed to try to take
whatever
and yes here
you
and look for me
don't see how you stop it
you
all right back determine
where could my opponent improve with
Alan
hmm
not sure
forgetting how the opening played out
maybe I'm putting a pond in the center
no I mean they they did have that they
played d4 there's a d4 d5 game tough to
sometimes suggest a different
arrangement
okay this the Knights are in their
natural squares
I think I'm just gonna put a knight on
f3
stay flexible with these guys I think I
want to go in for like a an English type
setup c4 and then night here
I could Castle next I'm going to do this
it's nice having the Queen right here
there's no surpassing
okay I'm alright if the Queen comes out
but do I need to do that no well yeah
here there's this
I'm okay with just taking with the Queen
I don't see any great sensitive points
in blacks position or just in this
position position 521
for let's do D for
I'm doing this move of all moves right
now because I don't want to allow black
to set up a pawn in the center so that
is now very conservative
and this Bishop is going to struggle
you
let's let this night
get on his best square
not sure what I would want to
I'm probably just going to do this
right now so I have a good pawn Center
I guess he's gonna be developed by way
of d2
and let's see a great night jump
No
this is maybe useful take out a square
from the black pieces
this is useful
home pretty weird arrangement I'm just
going to tuck back here
he is unprotected that is one thing
let's give him a shove if he goes to d5
I could take and then there's this
uncomfortable pin
I'm gonna go here he pretty much needs
to be captured
and my bishop from e1 is striking at the
night this is a vulnerable point
okay I'm gonna go one step further
this is winning
there's just too much
going on here
I don't know how you yeah
they're Knights hanging
following
you
I think I want them
this one a divot I'd want to connect
rooks
Knight takes e5
take c5 and then there
not sure why I did that
feels like my light-square bishop is
killer
96 is serious these guys are almost both
paths you don't see that
so often
I'm gonna be up a piece soon
it is a full-piece
and to pick up a pawn with check put a
knight in the center threatening
smothered mate stuff maybe here there's
a fork
tonight is a super invasive a night
working against just these two guys
yeah a great pest
and we're seeing a reason why
better to go here doesn't really matter
follow up
all right Wow basically already at the
halfway point where we stand here 16s a
couple 16s in there four games in for me
JN Dana
time flying this guy 30-some seconds
still what do we do with this
arrangement
efore
what's vulnerable this guy now I got I
got things covered okay this is going to
be an awkward one
who can argue with putting a pawn in the
center got some support here now the
next phase if I do this this move is
annoying I don't know how I can how I
can really address this threat against
my pawn
can I get in c3 Knight c2 and d4 as a
way to build up a Center
I think on see through there bc5
I'm gonna try it
feels a little off I think they'll they
should be going for one of these too
let's put my knight here
I could be a little bit annoying
okay let's let's baby step it
here here I don't want this pawn to
restrict
yeah
let's go here
I want to stop this advance
what else do I want to stop
I want to do this right now I don't want
to see this move he also needs to see
night see to my queen could kind of get
stuck okay they're really gearing up for
that move but you know what they don't
have enough support for that
my bishop is now controlling that square
so they'd have to move this first
and now with that I'm gonna get this guy
working
preparing to meet this with this and I
have a little bit of space and this
structure would really kill the bishop
that is not a good move I don't think
do this with tempo now let's just step
up with my bishop so I can castle on way
down on time I get Castle kingside now
hmm
I don't know if I want a Castle kingside
oh I have this option I had that on a
last move
now it's even more appealing though so
now I'm taking like this I'm getting the
dark square bishop
let's Castle kingside
things are working out very good now
dark square weaknesses this rook
not well placed their queen is still
back a night on this square would be
excellent rook here more forceful stuff
like this but I don't know if I want to
do this I feel like I could try to maybe
win this pawn outright
let's start with this
night here I go here just to control
them
I'm getting out of the way that Queen
could see let's go here on her home
square
that
[Music]
is that one really concerned me control
the night
I want night here let's do it the other
night might reeve it might get to this
square
I just dropped upon don't see it
hope yes okay they didn't see it let's
go to
shame away
run oh he has to go to the corner
keep flushing nights away
good because then I hit him with a fork
the night has to go to one of these two
okay now now we blast open the position
we take the material and say let's open
it up for the exchange
here we go
my LightSquared bishop wants to see
let's break down the light squares
next
got a target here in the corner
I didn't see that move
let's just keep moving forward though
I'm taking with my cane if Bishop takes
rook
him right here I don't even have to take
that though
I could take here with check
pantech screen takes
you just I was so stupid spending so
much time on that
get out of the pen I just gave up that
pawn are you kidding me why'd I do that
oh this one has gone downhill
I should have just captured
I'm floundering
and giving up upon
no they're light squares
you
oh man should've never got to this point
and I got a time burning stuff
time burn and stuff
you
hmm can I even get that pond back
you
Wow back to tournament why did I let it
get to that point
you know I was going to do there if
night takes I wasn't going to take
my bishop because I would still have
possibilities to win with just a bishop
it's considered a win
that's a new rule well that was an
adjustment made some time ago but yeah
sneaky sneaky
they didn't pull off Knight takes pawn
though so it didn't matter
ah man
Oh bishop there to take my rook back I
should have just captured on d7 I didn't
realize Knight c7 was ready to pick up
my pawn silly I liked how I played that
to a certain point
okay what do we do here Sicilian like
stuff
let's see most important moment right
here
18 seconds
I guess I'm going to try a Sicilian like
move
it'll tie in well with my bishop for one
I have a square for my knight
he's a problem
yeah I think I'm gonna run it like like
this I can't get in this move so then he
needs to see
let's go here right now
okay this is like the RIP is demoted
and okay so now let's focus on a dark
square I'm ready to castle you're really
going to get that move in
hmm
I guess you are
but let's put my knight here I'm
preparing to meet this move with this
let's do this one right now strike in
the center
maybe I do this
I want a castle very soon
you
I don't like taking that night
I'm gonna go here
I need to free up my night was silly on
this square
just kind of clogging things up I want
my bishop to see maybe here
I need to counsel but I don't think
that's the most important thing to do
right now
okay that move
fellow
here I have that
an option so you can't strike in the
center long-term this could be an issue
backward pawn minor peaceless position
one way to view it just just a major
peace position and we're good here we
have something to bite out
let's castle
here I guess and get ready to go on the
D file
not sure which work is best
let's go here
let's take now they can't take with this
pawn
mmm the taking I thought this was
reasonable trying to get that in
okay let's see if I could not drop upon
No let's go here I was tempted by this
move but
be prepared for this if I did this here
takes rook takes Mike we would have to
move so let's just move it right now
okay
let's go here
and now here
what if he comes under fire
I'm not sure what to make of that okay
let's see if I could provoke this move
they drop back here threaten a bishop
trap
threatening to chop the bishop now their
king is without a good pocket
that's all that's an issue
trade
and go here
six is a pretty annoying move
think I want the Queen's off
now let's go here control Queen f6 move
both the both the bishops are preventing
the rook from getting to this second
I'm straight to go here don't do that
whatever you do don't move your King
here and allow mating one
that worked out really well what I just
did there she try that one more often
clean exchange huh
let's try I should have done this
instead of the King move
I got rook activity
bishop here there was a pawn push my
king is actually super active now i got
a pond
bishop here next
okay that's a mistake
Oh what I just did is a mistake
you
why did I allow that
it's a draft they go Bishop here
to draw anyway
you
No
now to
that's a win
lucky dog you lucky dog Wow
bishop they had an opportunity to just
exchange bishops there and i don't know
what a what a game
what an interesting position we worked
with there okay team white I'm getting
berserk by Grandma
getting berserk by Grandma
oh it's late in the stream
okay silly town
put-upon in the center
no one wants to get berserk by Grandma
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna have to wrap the stream
up very soon that's enough of this
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
let's go
my night cover this square really you're
okay with that structure
okay
let's go night ooh
the bishop check fortunately I do have
this move let's counsel
okay now my queen
my queen needs to play and I'm gonna
play something aggressive like b4
but I these guys are now doubled now so
that's the that's the idea
that though
don't you have any
soon
grammar
fish up here Pinner Oni
they don't want it
Wow I'm gonna hang on to him then
I'll give up upon
Graham is under a minute Graham is in
first
I don't know
I don't know what to think sometimes
just give that bishop a shove
I guess I don't like weakening my king
position but I'm off a piece
I could survive
under 40
let's a strike at g7
and then they'll take upon
the other taken
we'll go here
just going to take with the Queen
soon to be up a full rook if they don't
take care
here
sweeping on in now they resigned back to
chairman
we got 24 I have my chance for her first
how's this guy doing is he in a game
he's in a game how's that one looking
started
spyridon
spear done versus okay yeah Wow okay and
this guy still probably new here okay
I'm gonna get a couple more games in
don't think I want to preserve just yet
how this one plays out
sensitive points where are you
starting with this
you know I have these covered by my king
this one can't really be struck at
either sometimes some really sensitive
squares
let's put him here
sure what I want to do with him I could
counsel Kings side now probably this
I'm gonna be more aggressive with my
beep on help my bishop and strike at c5
love to see this this would help my
development
my bishop can come out
he's six bishop here what's the future
of this guy
you want to go
let's try this what's worth their queen
and ago she's kind of boxed in
and I think the Bishop's going to camp
out here
afraid of that one it's a fine move
you might have wanted to go here anyhow
okay he's just backing up so
yeah I don't know how much of an
improvement it is to have them one step
here unless he's somehow making use of a
three
let's go here step up
to move our our nights
okay
you
all right I guess I'll castle
he needs to do something this is my
problem piece
okay playing in the center huh
another thing I want to take once
you
thinking about taking here
it's not the immediate recapture yeah
that's different
interesting because now they're getting
this square
let's let's go let's go like this
pawn takes knight now I'm helped some
wait a second are these pawns all going
to go in a pacman here chop-chop-chop
that can't be good okay now I take upon
yeah pond is a pond right
bego bishop here
first
just take the part
ninety-five Bishop e4 I'm up upon he's
past as well
so let's look to push them
some
minute 10
Bishop e49 2d6
okay I just dropped this palm it's so
much further the extra phone does not
want him
I'll take let's just throw a quick
at the queen
and get my rook pine
I got this covered probably up three the
night can't move it on g2
here okay that move is a piece
under 40
flight Square will be h6
defend
care about losing this pawn
with the bishop I don't want to ruin my
structure
whoa no no what am I talking about my
queen would be attacked I didn't even
see if the bishop moved and it was check
I didn't even realize my queen was under
fire there
normally that would be the first thing I
would do is there a bishop move that
could be made with check in that case no
go to
and they just don't have any time
you
no time
me if they take the phone
their flight square covered
okay is this guy in the game again yes
get him grandma grandma grandma berserk
they both berserk oh that's a big one
okay I got a game I got a focus here
[Music]
I'm gonna try it
I'm gonna try Oh double berserk I love
that
okay so 90 second game
here we go
and go here
Knight c3 knight in here
oh my god oh my god I just dropped a
piece yeah he's kind of important oh man
not cool that was a free bishop yepper
man a tall pond on top of it
come on night work some magic
got mating ideas now he's there to
defend remember I don't have a dark
square bishop unless he goes here
that's scary town why are they giving me
that pond by the way I don't know
compensation time it oh boy
back to tournament land help me
their game is still going
get on grandma
for Grandma and that's a berserk when
he's going to get five we're going to
get paired up
I mean after berserk this guy he just
won we're gonna get paired up this is
for all the marbles
now I'm getting grim again okay grandma
come on
berserk me back here we go why did I get
paired with Grandma
oh okay
I didn't even think about this
arrangement
okay
fork
watch out for the fork
I could take him out
building a Center get castled okay my
pieces are following on very good
squares now all of a sudden
you poison
let's just meet any pawn push with
which I don't want things to open up
over here
and
where's their king gonna live
I want to go here and shut down the
bishop
a bishop no he's defended
under a minute
I hope his game doesn't finish
how do I know it's a he
Graham is in the think tank still go
here
and controls these light squares okay
all right
over here this is what I want next
where's the king gonna live
and stake
we'll grab that pun
come back to defend
I could take here
covered
going after the pawn
bum bum
Queen takes rook
that's some perpetual
sneaky
very sneaky
let's defend my most sensitive point
I think it was a perpetual
don't fall for me one and you're good
okay this is I could take now
you
yeah there's nothing
let's just give a check
you
yeah there's nothing no time they
resigned back to tournament and we're
not going to get another one in the
pairings are closed this guy there's
only a minute left John wick don't you
dare let this of this character win
from John wicks perspective go John wick
it's looking good for John wick
also he only has 23 seconds come on 45
seconds left on the tournament clock
yeah he's up the exchange
and upon
there you go John wick do a little time
burning action
oh no okay
yeah this one shouldn't finish
soon right up a full rook
only ten seconds left
all right
four three two one
and they continue to play the confetti
is mine I'll take it
38 34:28
25 24 24 2016 all
one of my favorites just 960 let's see
how the pages
to
three four five
six and a seven
all righty to the 63 of you games off
you